Auto was the 27 16 to 45 the small town of berries and Edmonds.
England's set a grizzly record that day 18 men and women were hangs together as
witches.
There was the single biggest mass execution for witchcraft in English history
and it was all the work of one man.
Matthew Hopkins was many things.
It's having owner,
a former lawyer,
the dedicated puritan,
but to the people of various and Edmonds.
He had only one title worth knowing and that was which find a general.
The son of a minister,
Hopkins began applying as gruesome trade in 1645 at the height of the first
English civil war together with as associate John,
he was personally responsible for the torture and execution of more women than
every single English which find in the previous century,
but Hopkins,
his tail is more than just a catalog of atrocity.
It's a tale of what can happen when an entire nation to comes to fear and mass
hysteria.
Today,
we're going to examine how one zealous man managed to corrupt England's sole
when Matthew Hopkins was born in when I'm Suffolk,
probably in 1620 it was into a world that was alive with superstition.
A king was on the throne,
King James the first.
He didn't just believe in witches,
but had literally written the book on them called demonology,
Britain's fastest growing religious movement.
Puritanism took it for granted that Satan himself walks to the byways and the
country lanes of England's Hopkins.
This meant a childhood that was practically drowning and superstition is father
John was a puritan minister who preached fire and Brimstone as was his uncle and
his one of his brothers.
It's likely they even had a copy of demonology lying around the house.
We say likely here because there's a lot we actually don't know about Matthew
Hopkins.
His early life,
while centuries of legends claimed that he did this all that the historical
record is actually pretty sparse.
Take his education.
There's some evidence that he may have gone to Holland to finish his schooling
just as the some evidence.
He may have trained as a lawyer,
but we're going to be honest with you and simply say that we just don't know.
Maybe all of that is true,
but maybe none of it is.
What is true is that is harder passed away at some point.
It's likely around 1635 come 1614 Matthew moved 10 miles down the road to
manningtree in Essex,
local law hazard that he purchased the Thorn in,
in nearby mislead,
but really that's just another gas,
but it's here that the guesswork finally ends.
We know that Hopkins was in manning tree by the end of 1640 we also know that he
was around in 19 or 20 years old,
and that's important because 1640 was the year that the peaceful England of
Hopkins is.
Youth finally fractured into a billion jagged pieces.
It was time for the first English civil war.
If you've watched our video on Oliver Cromwell and modesty aside,
it does make a useful crib sheet for this entire period.
You'll know that 1640 ended with a Scottish army occupying the north of England
and King Charles the first to being forced to call the new parliaments to raise
taxes.
Okay.
Now the INS and outs of this don't really matter for today's story,
but the upshot is that this led to something called the long parliament,
which led to some of the gold,
the grounds remonstrance switch in 1642 led to Charles' deciding to crush
parliaments in a war.
And look,
I know we're really missing out a lot of stuff here.
Don't have too much of a go at me in the comments.
This is really just a super condensed timeline in order to give you just some
background information.
Now,
the wall was really housing England as civil wars tend to be local courts were
suspended in many regions and law and order.
It kind of broke down into usable.
This came famine,
fuel shortages and biting poverty.
Places like the eastern England's where Hopkins lived,
where particularly hard hit much of the east with staunchly Puritan and pro
parliament,
which was a huge problem when nearby Oxford was the base of the king's NTP and
army.
To use a crude analogy,
living in Essex during the dog days of the war would have been like living in
Poland shortly after Annex Czechoslovakia.
You know,
the hammer is going to fall.
You just don't know when ends that waiting could send men mavs men like Sir
Hospital grimstone that can 1640 the livestock on.
So grins,
Don's vast estate and estate that included Hopkins.
His new home had begun to be plagued by mysterious illnesses as the ongoing wild
west and the situation the local peasantry turned to superstition in order to do
explain things before long,
they were certain that it has to be the work of a witch.
And in 1645 they finally identify top.
Elizabeth Clark was an elderly widow living on so grim lands them on Shay Lynch
mob.
A villages presented her to sa Grimson as the source of all his woes,
like the good Christian.
He was.
So Grinstein recommended Elizabeth Clark for trial.
All right,
so at this point we do need to take a quickly back in time because I want to
give you some background information on which trials in England's because a,
it's super interesting and B,
because it will help you understand how terrifyingly unique Hopkins was prior to
the era we're talking about,
which ones haven't really been a thing in England's been the medieval period,
which is actually seen as healers and pillars of their communities.
It wasn't until 1563 I'm sorry,
Elizabeth.
The first that the bill against conjugation ends witchcraft and sorcery and
enchantments made witchcraft illegal.
Even then it was barely illegal eagle,
the first major,
which trial in 1566 pounds.
All three defendants guilty and sentence them to just a single year in prison.
That's right.
No torture,
no burning at the stake,
just 12 months in the neck.
Now we need to be clear that English women were executed for witchcraft in this
period.
Unlike on the consonant,
though their deaths were closer to lynchings.
Local magistrates would get caught up in a panic and sign the death warrants.
I need to be later punished by their superiors.
For the incredulous fools executions weren't government policy and less the
which was using how supposed powers to commit other capital crimes like murder.
Now,
that all changed when James the first ascended to the throne on March the 24th
at 1603 Elizabeth first to breathed her last in the chili rooms of Richmond
palace badly was she called before,
has success of James.
The first was ramming anti,
which legislation through parliaments.
James the first was obsessed with witchcraft in 1589 had been on a boat that
nearly sank in a storm that was blamed on witches and the experience sent him
just the little cookies.
In 1597 he published demonology the which finding book that James Hopkins had
kept lying around Matthew's childhood home in 1604 James.
The first terms of this personal obsession into legal reality,
parliament passed the witchcraft statute which made the very active using
witchcraft rather than the spells affects a capital offense.
If that sounds like splitting has the results suggest otherwise.
Eight years after the bill passed,
10 women were hanged in Pencil.
For witchcraft.
Four years later,
another nine was sent to the gallows and less stuck.
By the time you get to Elizabeth Clark's trial in 1645 which stalls had become a
fact of life in England,
the only remarkable thing about them was how comparatively restrains they were.
I remember this was the era of the worst Berg,
which draws went up to 600 witches were burned alive in Germany against such
mass slaughter nine or 10 being hanged was pretty mild.
Unfortunately though,
things wouldn't be modeled for much longer.
Back in Mannington 1645 and Matthew Hopkins had gotten wind of and bending
trial.
For whatever reason,
something about this news lit a fire in his solve burns like the fires of hell.
Despite having no training and no legal standing,
Hopkins decided it was his duty to get involved with Clark's prosecution.
It was a decision that would very soon lead to the bloodiest,
which panic in English history.
Hmm.
In is 1647 Berg.
The discovery of witches,
Matthew Hopkins would claim is which one's in career began in 1644 however,
all evidence suggests it was here with Elizabeth Clark in March of 1645 that he
really got into which finding no one is sure of the exact timeline,
but it seems the Hopkins was approached by a man 10 years.
His senior names John Stern,
originally from Lowe's in Suffolk.
How exactly they got talking is unknown,
but it's student transpired that stern shed.
Hopkins is sharply defined view of good and evil.
Together they agreed to make clock confess to our sins.
At this point in English history torture.
It was illegal to it as it's a confession suspected,
which is would be monitored by watches to see if they summoned any familiars or
started zooming around on broomsticks or something like of that.
Clock had been watched for several days now and so far nothing had happened.
That wasn't until Hopkins and stone showed up despite having no legal authority
to do so.
Hopkins and stone convinced the watchers to turn Clark's interrogation over to
them.
They took her to the born in and what happens next is shrouded in mystery.
Hopkins would laser claimed that they witnessed car call her familiars amps in
the animal form to the end,
including a demonic bunny rabbit named just sugar and friends.
No,
we're not making this up.
More likely,
Hopkins and Stan,
they tortured the poor old women.
Either way,
the result was the same cock confess to being a witch and she started naming
other witches as well.
Armed with these new names done in Hopkins approach the out of Hardwick who was
presiding over clocks trial impressed by the young men's initiative,
Holloway gave stunned and official warrants to find more witches in Mannington
Hopkins.
He was made as a systems.
It wouldn't be long before their roles were reversed.
Though.
Over the next few weeks,
Hopkins and Stan conducted their inquiries.
The five women named by Clark were all taken in and interrogated and Zillow Vitu
confessed and gave up more names.
Within no time,
it's all the witch finders of jails.
23 women and Mannington was in the grip of a full blown which panic pure in and
Nahum Maya Wellington recorded the whole thing,
including the lurid testimony of Rebecca West who'd been jailed by Hopkins
alongside her mother Ran West plains,
that she had been forced to have sex with the devil and that Oni am mother's
death could save half from Satan's spell.
The jury obliged by having an hanged.
By the end of the Essex trials,
18 women had been hanged,
including Elizabeth clock further for more had died in jail.
I knew Rebecca West Dude sacrificed her own mother was finally set free.
It was the deadliest which panic to of Efa hit England's,
even if Hopkins and Stern had never tried another,
which the Essex trials would still be famous boy into by his success in manning
tree,
perhaps enjoying the new found celebrity Hopkins bestowed upon himself the title
of which find general oms with Hardwick Suarez.
Ian's done headed east following in the wake of the shocking news of Clark's
execution.
It was this news that became the spark that would turn the east of England's
into an inferno.
And December,
1643 the provost marshal of the parliamentarian,
Eastern Association,
conditioned William Dousing to destroy all non puritan icons in Suffolk dousing
took to the job like an extremist Dr Water Way.
In 1645 he rampage across the east burning churches,
vandalizing icons and encouraging puritan extremism.
Eventually dousing zealotry got so frightening that Oliver Cromwell personally
stripped him of his commission.
By then the damage it was done,
dozens of towns across Suffolk had been reduced to rex that populations either
cowed or swept up and religious fervor.
It was these people who two years later would call upon the which find a general
as they left behind the debt of manningtree tree ans ventured into Suffolk in
1645 Hopkins and Stan charted a course that took them to many of the towns
dowsing had previously swept through.
It's a move it straight from the modern extremist playbook.
Identify a person or community already damaged by extremism,
like dowsing smashing of icons and push them even further into madness.
Just as isis did on the water and plans of Iraq.
Hopkins and Susan found an audience in dancing's ruined villages.
The pads,
the modus operandi,
it was simple as they traveled the witch finders,
which led to villages know that they were in the area.
The villagers responded by inviting the men.
Yup.
They really did invite them like a pair of misogynistic vampires.
Hopkins and Stan never ends it.
A victim's home without an invite.
In normal times,
this would have ensured that crackpot adventure and did as soon as it had began
about,
well,
these were no more times.
People were afraid,
afraid that the king's army would kill them,
that that children would staff and that they would freeze to death in the winds
up in another historical contacts,
not,
yeah,
it might have been timed on Jews or illegal immigrants or bending of the
outsider group.
In England's of 1645 it was turned on.
Women once invited into a village,
Hopkins and Stan sent to work on suspected,
which is unlike the thumbscrew happy sadists in Europe,
Hopkins,
his interrogation methods wouldn't sort of looks out of place in a CIA handbook.
Victims were made to sit absolutely still without sleep for days on end.
Others were logged in isolation and denied food or anything but water.
The others were made to exercise for hours and hours every day until they were
ready to drop at the ends of all this psychological torture,
the accused,
they nearly always confessed.
Hopkins then forced them to name more,
which is in the village who would intend confess and so on and so forth.
That's not to say that the stories you've heard about Hopkins aren't true.
He really did test if some women were witches buying,
tying them up and throwing them into rivers,
those that drowns.
They were innocent and there's that.
Fluted has magic powers and they were executed for all this bloodshed,
Hopkins and Stan,
and anywhere between six pounds and 23 pounds per village at the high ends.
That's roughly equivalent to 5,000 pounds or $6,500 today it said the Hopkins
made a thousand pounds during his career as a witch finder at a time when the
average labor is wage was a mere six pence per day death.
In short,
it made Matthew Hopkins filthy rich.
Not The hands done actually hung around for the death boss.
That confessional.
Let's do the witch finder general and his assistant would vanish into the night,
leaving the accused to their fates and what fates.
These were.
In August of 1645 and 80 year old minister called John Loughs was forced to run
on the spot without sleep until he collapsed from exhaustion.
On the 27th of the month,
18 women and men were hanged together outside berries and Edmonds,
the West mass execution of any English,
which scat and yet that's right.
Men were killed,
just which is to Hopkins was responsible for the execution of between 17 and 20
men for witchcraft during his career,
including three husbands who were killed alongside their wives.
But let's not kid ourselves.
Gender was an important factor in determining if you survived a meeting with
Matthew Hopkins.
In that same space of time when he killed 20 men,
Hopkins sends an estimated 200 women to the guys in September of 1645 the witch
finder general committed is most notorious acts as the doc and I drew in Hopkins
and Stern arrived in Ipswich that they tried and convicted Mary Lakeland's in a
shocking break with tradition rather than hanging out.
They decided to burn her alive as the black smoke coiled into the sky over
Rashmir Heath Hopkins pocketed his fee and left.
Perhaps he had married Lakeland screams and felt sorry for her,
but perhaps they made him feel good.
This was the Fallis Day in the history of English,
which I'm saying thankfully it would also be one of the lost
cause.
I mean it's something you might not have expected during this whole Gyn aside
thing.
Hopkins and Stan hadn't exactly been hiding from the authorities that EDC has
reported.
The Hopkins may have been paid for his work by official government sources.
Whether that's true and also there's no denying the which finding general soon
came to the attention of parliaments back in August of 1945 Hopkins,
his conviction of John Lowe's,
that old guy that he forced to run up and down until he collapsed,
had resulted in a which panic and berries and Edmonds that eventually saw a
hundred people.
Jails had,
Hopkins had his way,
all 100 of them would have been executed,
but word of the gigantic which trial leaked to parliament.
It was simply too big to be credible.
So parliament said that own people out to retry,
everyone convicted by Hopkins.
This time the trials would be more careful.
They would be less tainted by bias,
which is why on August the 27th only 18 which were hanged,
it buries and Edmonds rather than the 100 that Hopkins had hoped for.
Of course,
hanging 18 people for made up magic is still deranged.
But here's the thing.
Parliaments,
which homes is a model of sanity compared to Hopkins and it's done in light of
the near mess are berries into Edmonds.
Many mps began to wonder if Hopkins was actually a bigger danger than the
witches that he was finding.
It helps this by fall of 1645 the conditions that had allowed mass hysteria to
flourish,
they were on the wane.
The Battle of navy in June that year had seen the remaining royalist forces,
mostly crushed.
The wall was now winding down and with,
it's the famine,
hunger,
and fear that had driven the which panic swells as well as 1646 dawn's the tide
of public opinion has decisively turned against the witch finders.
The purex and Minister John Gold published a pamphlet that attacks Hopkins in no
uncertain terms for the slaughter that he was inflicting on.
The countryside goal was someone who actually believed in witches,
but even he could see that the witch finder general was Zadek in patrol.
Hopkins tried to find back.
He wrote ghoul a chilling.
Nathan has something to come look for,
which is in his area.
If goal ever criticized him again,
he and Stan,
they stepped up their visits to villages,
but the game,
it was already up on April the 27 1646 Charles the fast was forced to flee
Oxford after it fell to parliamentary forces.
Although the king would escape being taken into custody for some weeks.
The first English civil war,
it was either no long offset.
Parliaments Summon Tompkins and Stan accusing them of the illegal use of
torture.
Hopkins was now famous but not as a savior of the purists and faith rather as a
likely Charlotte and who'd sent countless women to their deaths.
By August,
1646 Hopkins has credibility with public.
It was shot.
Villages no longer sought him out.
The powerful no longer defended his work,
possibly scad parliaments,
mice,
try him in turn,
the witch finder general discounted this phony title and retired back to manning
treat his entire,
which I was in Korea I took,
lasted less than 18 months.
Still.
Hopkins had his blood money and he was respected by some of the most zealous
puritans,
thanks to his reputation,
and he was able to publish his book,
the discovery of witches in 1647 when the first edition has reached New
England's,
they smart off a series of which panics that would culminate in the infamous
1692 Salem witch trials.
Well,
the Hopkins would live to see the last grizzly fulfillment of his legacy in
August of 1647 at the age of just 26 or 27 Matthew Hopkins killed over and
manning tree and died.
While legend says that he was tried as a witch using his own methods and
executed,
the mundane reality appears to be this tuberculosis carried them off.
Yes.
Even as Hopkins died,
the whales,
he helped create.
It was already feeding.
Okay.
By the end of 1648 the vast majority of English women accused of witchcraft web
being acquitted,
even when the second and third English civil wars blew up,
followed by Oliver Cromwell's puritan dictatorship.
Nothing like the which panics of 1645 took hold again 40 years later in March of
60 and 84 Alicia Marlin's became the last person to be put to death for
witchcraft in English history.
That would be more trials including an infamous one in 1717 but never again
would they result in a verdict of execution.
Now,
let's flash forward to 1735 of full 90 years after Matthew Hopkins as Ghoulish
Specter,
last rooms,
the English countryside.
The greatest Robert Walpole was the prime minister and the superstitions of the
17th century had given way to the scientific curiosity of the 18th that year
parliament passed the witchcraft act.
It repealed all previous which laws and all punishments for witchcraft.
Instead of penalize,
pretending to be a witch for profit or to influence others.
Think about that for a second.
Within Living Memory,
Matthew Hopkins had slaughtered more than 200 women for being witches.
Now the law stated that such a thing was impossible.
The witchcraft was nothing more than a pretense,
a humbug.
We like to think that that new sent Matthew Hopkins Rolling in his grave.
Finally on June the 13th 1782 Swiss execution has dragged on a Goldie outdoor
fields and lopped off her hat.
The bloods,
that pattern down onto the grass would be the last blood that would ever be
spilled in Europe.
Switch hunts over the previous three centuries,
over 200,000 women had perished at the hands of the consonants.
Inquisitors 300 years of misogynistic murder had finally come to an end,
but the story,
it doesn't quite stop there in 1921 garden is we're doing some work on a house
in the villages since Osa.
Then assets.
When did they found a pair of female skeletons dating from the error of the
English,
which draws the two unknown women had iron reverts driven through their joints
to stop rising from the grave.
It was a chilling of visceral reminder of Hopkins and his methods transported
forward to the 20th either now traces of his superstitious,
well,
if you still linger over the countryside and local hills and forgotten heath
named for the tortures that he inflicted there,
or the helpless women who died under them,
Hopkins may be gone,
but his legacy lives on the next time you hear spooky tales of which drowse
oases.
Someone dressed as a witch for Halloween.
I remember that.
Just spare a thought for all of the women who died at the hands of England's,
which find a general.
So I hope you found the video interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos just like this several times a week.
And if you're looking at something else to watch right now,
why not check out one of our other videos linked to on the screen now I've also
got another channel top tens find that linked in the description below.
And as always,
thank you for watching.